alors la petite fille vanessa comet a
vendu des spatules c'est non je pense
qu'on va pas demander pardon mais
patronyme pas loin d'un million d'argent
alors je sais que c'est quelqu'un de
deux liés aux valeurs de ce monde
après chaque mois tu peux nous chantait
joe sexy or tu vas pas de chanter en
espagnol as si je chante on espère y
penser ça ce soir
toi tu peux pas de chanter toi ça sera
difficile de ne pas le faire juste une
phrase hadassah je préférerais que ce
soit l indique c dans une chanson de
céline qui connaît par coeur les deux
énormes yahoo
je ne peux pas commenter ce petit jeu
mais allégé de quelques très violent je
te trouvais sharon un vilain soir je ne
te ferait dans la micro n'y de grands
pourront très bien j'avais cela paradis
en 1900 et comme arielle dombasle milieu
urbain bouche devient koi 15 ans atteint
à peu près 15 ans alors vanessa vous
êtes né en 1972 à saint-maur-des-fossés
votre père andré était président
directeur général d'une miroiterie
seulement 10 mai d'une miroiterie
faisait des poutres en polyuréthane
abondamment et avait des miroirs dont il
écoutera par anton polyuréthane et votre
mère corinne était directrice de la
société c'est ça elle a été oui un peu
plus tard j'avais une tombe comptable
dans l'association des parents très uni
non je dis ça parce que vous avez des
parents très uni 30 ans que ça vous sert
de modèle vous pour monter un numéro
attribué dès l'âge de 4 ans vous prenez
des cours de piano et de danse rythmique
et vous monter des petits spectacles est
alors un jour votre oncle comédien
didier pain remarque que votre joli brin
de voix et vous propose enfin propose à
vos parents que vous fassiez de l'école
des femmes voilà votre première
apparition à la télévision
oui enfin c'est bien c'est plus sain que
ça c'est mon oncle et il sait que j'ai
rêve de chanter que les comédies
musicales c'est tout ce qui me fait
rêver et et que comme les enfants de à
l'époque de mon âge regarde l école des
fans et et j'adorais la comédie musicale
emilie jolie et se trouve qu'ils avaient
fini chatel qui faisait les missions et
amy a emmené mais ce n'était pas là il
était pas producteur à l'époque c'était
pour faire plaisir sa nièce elle est
composée de huit ans et qu'on lui dise
en fait un 45 tours en association avec
les forbans qui s'appelle la magie des
surprises parties que vous avez fait
intervient on le trouve plus dix mois je
vais chercher je ne trouve pas assez un
collector si quelqu'un là pourquoi vous
voulez puissante 1 parce que j'ai je
n'aime pas beaucoup et se trouve que je
l'avais enregistré à 10 ans et quand
j'avais 13 ans il était toujours pas
sortis entre 10 et 16 ans là la voix
elle change puis surtout les les goûts
et les envies changent donc j'avais plus
envie de faire ça puis le disque est
jamais sorti et puis au moment où joe le
taxi est sorti là comme par hasard il
est certain en tout les cas vanessa
c'est grâce à cette chanson que vous
rencontrez franck langolff lors de
l'enregistrement de la maquette de
l'album de sophie marceau c'est ça non
jettent aller pour voir que vous la
voyez chanter dans le studio faisait
derrière la vitre qui vous dit quand
même c'est pas terrible
faire moins c'est ce qu'on vous dit
pourquoi pas moi comble avril en plus
j'y suis allé à l'époque au studio parce
que j'adore et sophie marceau à l'époque
et puis et puis j'ai rencontré franck
langolff et étienne roda-gil à cette
époque là et c'est vrai que je leur ai
dit votre dernier album studio c'était
en 94 donc et sept ans après en octobre
2000 vous sortez un nouvel album donc
chez barclays qui s'appelle bliss ce qui
veut dire félicite et vous savez comment
on fait montrez-lui lent
c'est en fait vous avez fait du cinéma
ces dernières années pour pour souffler
parce que le cinéma vous dites c'est un
peu une planque quoi c'est un peu des
vacances c'est dur de dire ça par
rapport au métier d'acteur qu'un métier
difficile mais par rapport à la chanson
et le fait de pas faire partie d'un
groupe d'être tout seul à assumer toutes
les responsabilités de d'être cinéma22
d'enfiler le costume d'un autre
personnage de laisser sa vie de côté et
la pression allait plus pour le metteur
en scène au cinéma
donc je trouve ouais c'est se reposant
certainement pas physiquement
et puis donc fait pas mal de films et
puis un jour ça ça commence à vous à
vous démange et quand même cette idée de
recommencer à chanter puis à bordeaux de
la ce a quand même pris trois ans et
puis vous avez fait un bébé
donc ça a été quand même assez long la
maturation de cet album 4 3 4 ans et là
après roda-gil après langolff après
kravitz après gainsbourg vous demander
avec qui travailler vouliez pas d'un
disque prêt à chanter ça d'habitude on
vous apportez des chansons et puis vous
choisissiez là vous voulez vraiment vous
impliquer beaucoup plus dans la
production du disque non oui j'avais
envie que ce soit que je que je fabrique
aussi
alors un jour et dans un studio comme ça
vous mettez devant un piano vous jouez
avec trois doigts et puis ça plaît à vos
copains vous dites je joue très mal mais
ça suffit pour écrire des chansons
vous pourrez pas que les gens qui sont
autour de vous à ce moment là ils vous
disent que c'est bien parce que c'est
vos copains d'abord c'était c'était
juste une personne et puis cette
personne n'a pas dit c'est bien je les
gelées vue sur son visage donc je peux
pas j'ai cru que c'était sincère
non mais c'est très complet vanessa
c'est très gonflé si vous avez fait
parce que non seulement vous avez écrit
des chansons en plus et produit l'album
j'en ai fait une partie
fait une autre partie avec matthieu
chedid et puis j'ai enfin il ya eu plein
de gens où tu veux en venir aux tirs il
a concrètement pensant je veux et is de
ballons gignac est plein de gens si
merde
enfin quand même si beaucoup impliqué
oui bien sûr mais vous dites c'est monde
dise quoi vous êtes mis au centre du
dispositif c'est ça que je veux dire oui
oui c'est bien sûr non si c'est vrai je
n'ai pas fait tout seul mais mais c'est
ça devait conlure parler de mon univers
et des choses des choses qui me touchent
non je veux savoir simplement c'est pas
un peu présomptueux c'est comme les
acteurs qui se mettent à vouloir
réaliser des films ça que je vais dire
est ce que c'est pas un peu présomptueux
contenu une chanteuse talentueuse certes
évidemment mais d'un surcoût de se dire
je peux aussi écrire je peux aussi
produire ça en fait mais je me suis pas
dit que je pouvais le faire
je les fais mais j'avais j'avais
beaucoup plus de certitudes
c'est didier golemanas ce qu'a écrit le
texte et la musique s'exécute vous bravo
alors je retire tout ce que je dis il a
participé d'ailleurs johnny depp on
écrit de musique ensemble et puis elle a
joué dessus sur un titre
vous êtes content tout va bien du disque
oui une fois que c'est terminé à un tas
de choses qu'on a envie de changer mais
au moins il faut s'arrêter alors sait-on
tournée en ce moment vous êtes et à lyon
le 10 mai le 11 à marseille le 12 à
toulouse le 16 à nancy le 30 au zénith
de paris le 1er juin à bruxelles
sur scène vous fait quoi et chante des
chansons des quatre albums par exemple
du rôle taxi par exemple dis lui toi que
je t'aime
c'est souvent que c'est commencer les
chanteurs on va les voir sur scène et
puis font leur dernier album ils font
pas les tubes qu'on adore alors
aujourd'hui vous avez fait cinq albums
cinq films et votre dernier film c'est
de tomber complètement à lola cette
histoire de don quichotte là c'est
horrible cette histoire non bah c'était
dur on est enfin au moment où ça s'est
passé puisque jean rochefort a dû se
faire opérer on était là pour lui c'est
un film certaine l'homme qui a tué dans
petit show de terry gilliam qui est un
grand réalisateur donc avec vous avec
johnny depp jean rochefort dans le rôle
de effectivement de don quichotte le
deuxième jour le plateau est inondé le
quatrième jour guillian découvre que le
paysage a changé de couleur etc il est
pur accord et qu'il faut tout refaire
le cinquième jour c'est horrible où
l'assistant découvre que rochefort peut
pas tourner ils se disputent il tourne
quand même il faut trois personnes pour
le faire descendre de cheval et le
sixième jour il a évacué sur sur paris
le tournage est interrompu et vous après
votre de trucs à faire vous avez votre
tournée puis j'imagine que johnny depp
il a aussi des engagements et le projet
est abandonné il devra jamais on verra
jamais ce film ça vous touche moins
qu'avant ce genre de trucs depuis que
vous êtes mère de famille vous avez
appelé votre album bichon ce que dira
féliciter vous dit finalement on pouvait
toujours dit que j'aimais pas beaucoup
qu'on parle de votre vie privée dans la
presse à la télévision et là dans cet
album bliss vous parlait que de ça c'est
un peu contradictoire non d'une certaine
façon
[Musique]
wave peut-être mais je ne raconte pas de
détails je parle de sujets universels
qui est qui qui concerne enfin une
grande partie des femmes y'a pas il n'y
a pas de détail a pas de deux ne s'est
pas un journal intime et puis c'était la
première fois que j'écrivais des
chansons que j'avais envie de parler des
des gens et des choses que j'aime le
plus elle est loin l'époque de saab
[Musique]
la seule chanson de florent pagny à
l'époque vous étiez ensemble vous avez
tellement de problèmes avec les
paparazzi qui avait fait cette chanson a
pas les paparazzi la presse écrit ce qui
est dit et prince parmi jamais souffert
de sa l'époque oui oui oui un pack vous
crois que ce n'est pas du tout cette
pression de la presse votre couple
aurait pu continuer un an
alors vous êtes attiré par les stars ou
c'est simplement parce que vous voyez
des stars dans votre milieu parce que
finalement vous êtes toujours été avec
des gens assez connus finalement la
gauche a pas connu de tous saïd sur le
foyer de la salle un contrat il ya deux
points chauds oubliez mabri parce qu'il
n'était pas dans ma wii non sérieusement
c'est pas vous êtes et florent pagny
lenny kravitz sera de jeux wii qui
arrivera il va venir voir les voies vers
10 heures histoire star c'est pas c'est
comment dire c'est pas c'est pas une
qualité c'est pas non plus un métier
avant d'être star on est star parce que
parce que on fait de la musique où on
écrit des livres où on est peintre où on
est star de deux boulangeries
mais comme quand on quand on aime
quelqu'un et quand mais attirés par
quelqu'un c'est c'est pour tout ce qu'il
représente et l'homme que j'aime
aujourd'hui c'est une star mais avant
d'être une star
c'est quelqu'un qui fait des choses que
j'admire forcément ça et jour quelque
chose des sims et plus c'est pareil au
départ en plus parce qu'il avait quand
même une réputation super houleuse nom
super difficile je ne sais pas car c'est
quelqu'un de c'est quelqu'un de juste et
qui réagit quand tu y es cantine quand
il réagit agressivement comme on a pu
voir ce à quelques fois c'est toujours
pour une bonne raison
en tout cas donné les raisons que je
dans les situations que j'ai vécue celle
d'avant je sais pas mais mais c'est vrai
que c'est tout mon passé qui fait les
choses comme quand il était avec winona
ryder ou kate moss il se battait
toujours il était toujours très agressif
depuis qu'il avait vu ses prix il avait
calmé fait c'est non je vais pas calmé
les lycées qu'elle met tout seul l'envié
mais quand quand ils scott ce genre
d'événements sont on en parle dans la
presse on a l'impression que c'est
arrivé 50 fois alors si triste arrivé
une fois mais comme on le répète 50 fois
l'impression que ça arrive tout le temps
mais c'est un secret tête
non j'ai j'ai lu ça à quelques fois et
j'ai comme si je l'avais donc t'es où
j'ai rien fait il a il a fait tout seul
le dompter sans rien faire j'ai rien vu
c'est donc là il est au pied en tous les
cas vous avez un enfant qui s'appelle
donc lily rose melody
ça va vous êtes besoin de personnes tous
les trois là tout va bien vous êtes dans
votre maison dans le midi tout ça c'est
calme c'est au pourquoi pas assez au
fait ce n'est pas ma route pour qu'ils
me disent elles ressortiront le moteur à
robert pascaud envie que je vienne
c'est bien d'avoir est ce que vous allez
vous marier
nous non c'est pas j'en sais rien on
n'en parle pas vous en parlez pas encore
on en parle on en parle pas ça s'est
passé pas quelque chose qui nous qui
nous paraît important pour l'instant
c'est maintenant français puis vous
dites je ne suis pas la meilleure
chanteuse du monde je ne suis pas la
meilleure actrice du monde mais c'est
tombé sur moi
des cadeaux du ciel oui beaucoup de
cadeau du ciel alors j'ai en même temps
je travaille quand même ça ça se nourrit
cette l'itif tout ça mais j'aime
beaucoup de cadeaux beaucoup trop de
chance
[Applaudissements]
alors vanessa paradis vous êtes devenue
une mère très très attentif vous êtes
ordonné maintenant avant vous vous
faites les valises quand vous partez en
quand vous partez en vacances était
fraîchement sérieuse donc confère une
interview très sérieuses et c'est
l'interview expliqué à ma fille en la
bouche pendant le dégagement raté
[Musique]
votre fille vous demande maintenant
pourquoi on meurt encore mineure ce
qu'il ya dans l'histoire il ya un début
un milieu et une fin
et puis il faut bien que ça s'arrête
sans bout d'un moment on devient
complètement à la ramasse et à la
cuillère mais après il ya autre chose
surtout je vous le dirai ça sert à quoi
de travailler puisqu'il suffit d'aller à
la machine pour prendre de l'argent
baa à occuper ses journées et a mangé
mon père est dit c'est le taxi de la
liberté l'argent j'aime bien cette
expression récurrents la meilleure maman
c'est quoi ce que vous mettez dans vos
cigarettes avec papa
ah oui j ai non j'aime explique pour
l'instant tassimo s'est dit ah bah ça va
ya pas de problème pas de problème non
mais de toute façon je lui expliquerai
je préfère à oui je préfère c'est depuis
ce passé les frontières tranquille
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
8 kg aussi aux états unis moi pourquoi
papa il a fait un baiser sur la bouche à
la baby sitter
bagis tirait mais parce que parce qu'il
aime bien qui voulait lui dire bonjour
puis après je fais 50 balles de leurs on
peut quand même par un bisou quoi maman
pourquoi on t'entend mois la radio en ce
moment parce que parce que les gens les
aiment pas trop méchants sont en ce
moment et dit maman qu'est la question
qui n'a pas de réponse c'est chiant les
gosses c'est pourquoi pourquoi je t'aime
pas de réponse c'est comme ça
[Applaudissements]
mais si vanessa paradis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que j'ai un moment ça faisait
un moment qu'on n'avait pas vu vanessa
paradis pour les 13 ans très heureux de
vous voir vanessa alors lors de notre
première rencontre c'était en 1987
c'était aux bains douches l'émission
s'appelait bain de minuit
c'était l'année de joe le taxi et les
paroles de la chanson était d' etienne
roda-gil magnéto serge alors la petite
fille vanessa comet a vendu triste est
une scène en gardant mon patron ou pas
loin d'un mignon c'est beaucoup d'argent
soit 72,5 et le clin d'oeil de lier aux
valeurs de ce monde tu peux nous
chantait joe le taxi
tu vas pas de chanter en espagnol et si
je le chanteur sting passé ce soir voilà
j'ai fait 20 minutes et en 1985 avec
étienne roda-gil vanessa paradis étienne
roda-gil qui nous a quittés récemment et
pour qui je voudrais qu'on ait une
pensée parce que c'est quelqu'un de tout
à fait important pour nous et pour vous
regarder comme un vraiment un type
exceptionnel
on l'a pas dit ici au moment où nous ça
s'est passé parce que c'était comme ça
et ce soir je suis ravi de lui rendre
hommage en votre compagnie vanessa
[Applaudissements]
etienne si tu le regardes comme dit
walker vite les regarde arte qui
détiennent ouais ouais bien sûr il
arrive on ne regarde pas ce soir vanessa
après cinq ans d'absence cinéma donc le
temps de faire deux enfants lily rose et
jack le temps d'un cd qui s'appelle
bliss et d'une tournée vous revenez dans
un film absolument barjots une comédie
de science-fiction qui s'appelle atomik
circus le retour de james bataille des
frères poireau alors c'est un film ovni
ascain c'est complètement un pitch à bhl
c'est une série z déjanté ça se passe
dans un village qui s'appelle scott
l'aide city un village rétro-futuriste
donc au fin fond des usa où on prépare
une grande fête c'est la fête de la
tarte à la vache avec une chanteuse qui
s'appelle contient c'est vous et un
cascadeur qui s'appelle james bataille
voilà alors dès son arrivée james
bataille séduit concha qui veut devenir
chanteuse
poussé par son père le patron du bar qui
jouait pas jean pierre marielle voilà
mais la fête se termine en catastrophe à
marie et parallèlement un météorite
s'écrase sur scott let libérant
d'étranges choses volante gens des
pieuvres des pierres volent en aveugle
dans les films américains des années 50
et la démarque
l'imprésario alan chiasse joué par
benoît poelvoorde
qui drague vanessa c'est un pitch assez
bien ce que je disais ces lignes est oui
c'est insensé ce film quand vous avez
reçu le scénario vous avez réagi comme
en ait beaucoup ri ouais beaucoup rick
passé de remettre les palmes dans
l'ordre c'est vrai qu'ils avaient pas
mal des choses incompréhensibles et 20
des choses pas très claires mais il y
avait un le ton qu'il ya dans le film
était déjà dans ce scénario le la bande
démo des frères poro qui avait fait
beaucoup de pub et des courts métrages
et des clips étaient vraiment un sens
c'est très très très original et puis
euh cdd garçon bourré de talent est
tellement sincère et je suis très fier
d'être de faire partie de ce film qui a
été fait en france par des français avec
des acteurs presque tous français et
vash est fier alors les frères poireau
effectivement ce sont des nantais 1 et
ils ont fait appel pour la musique à
d'autres nantais qui s'appelle les
petits lapins des little rabbits il ya
une chanson qui est très drôle c'est la
pétroleuse
nous allons michael berrer
m
plus
michel
[Applaudissements]
comme des robots
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
2-3 kerry ça arrive parfois je crois que
les gens le public n'accroche pas que
cette chanson non
c'est pas la peine de s'acharner on est
à plus tard la chanson c'est comme ça
qu'est ce que tu veux pas en droit de le
faire alors le disque sort chez barclays
ce qui veut dire que contrairement aux
rumeurs qui ont couru
vous n'êtes pas viré de chez barclays
s'attend vraiment non non c'est pas ma
tasse
ils ont fait d'autres chez barclay ouais
ceci étant en ce moment vous semblez
préféré vanessa paradis votre carrière
d'actrice à votre carrière de chanteuse
8e cinéma c'est les vacances de la
personnalité on devient quelqu'un
d'autre mais très entouré c'est vrai
alors que chanteuse
c'est d'une extrême solitude je préfère
pas je préfère passer le les projets la
ville de ça ça se présente comme ça et
puis je met plus de temps à faire les
chansons maintenant parce que je les
fais un petit peu moins avec l'aide
d'autres personnes et donc ça me prend
moncton ce que j'essaie de factrice et
l'on vous dit je ne suis pas gainsbourg
et puis les enfants prennent beaucoup de
temps
c'est moi qui le prend beaucoup de temps
avec mon enfant parce que je n'ai rien
envie de louper ces cerveaux les élevez
vous même quoi je suis donc allé faire
élever par d'autres préfèrent les élevez
vous même
alors question cinéma quand même vous
venez de tourner avec le scénariste de
la fille sur le pont qui s'appelle
manqué qui a réalisé son premier film
voilà qui est un petit bijou c'est
encore quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup qui
a écrit qui écrit une histoire sublime
et amorce et je viens juste de finir de
le tourner donc c'est encore assez frais
avec un jeune acteur qui s'appelle
vincent rottiers il faut retenir son nom
parce que c'est une une bombe atomique
une perle en règle à 17 ans et c est ce
que tu es à son portable à vincent
rottiers un attaché de presse
on va demander qu'il l'appelle pour
l'inviter tout de suite leur oui alors
en tous les cas ce qu'on peut dire
vanessa c'est vous fait pas d'effort
particulier pour tournée en amérique
vous dj aucune ambition internationale
il vous est même pas d'agent hollywood
non non non pourquoi
mais parce que j'ai enfin ils ont déjà
ils ont des gens très très bien ils ont
pas franchement besoin de quoi qu'ils
ont besoin d'eau à moins que ce soit un
projet enfin quelque chose de spécial
mais il faut faire la course aux
premières impressions vous tout le temps
est leur moi qui tourne quand même une
fois tous les 36 du mois là bas il
faudrait tourner toul en tout le temps
pour jamais qu on vous oublie puis parce
que je franchement j'ai eu moi j'ai tout
ce qu'il me faut ici en france puis j'ai
un peu peur l'europe pourquoi je voyage
je n'ai pas déjà ça me prend beaucoup de
temps
il fallait en plus que je fasse ça là
bas puis c'est bien là bas on ne montre
pas du doigt
si c'est ça je finalement non c'est pas
vrai si voici maintenant elle élève ses
enfants elle veut pas faire la course à
hollywood
vous êtes assez sage moi je suis très
normal c'est très ennuyeux c'est bien
non pas du tout enfin je sais pas ce
qu'en pense votre johnny depp mais moi
personnellement je trouve ça bien il a
faim il a peur de se plaindre
apparemment fait longtemps que c'est
tentant de suis quand même temps 6
c'est bien déjà un et vous michel c'est
quand même temps et votre femme
trois mois alors vous avez passé sa vie
trop bien déjà
ça va ces trois mois les premiers mois
c'est les plus durs dg alain nous vivons
ensemble depuis trois mois
oui sommes pas mariés encore trois mois
c'est les noces de bistrot non vanessa
est toujours pas mariés non plus un
médecin j'ai des enfants alors vanessa
vous n'avez toujours pas de projet avec
johnny depp qui a eu cette histoire de
don quichotte pour laquelle nous avons
reçu jean rochefort ici l'année dernière
pour la sortie du dvd bon aventure
avortée terrible histoire évidemment et
c'est vrai qu'après le succès de pirates
des caraïbes qui a fait quand même 621
millions de dollars de recettes énormes
la suite est déjà en chantier donc voilà
il est happé par sa est en fait
effectivement vous concentrer sur votre
rôle de maman surtout à los angeles où
vous passez votre temps entre les cours
de danse pour les enfants les ateliers
d'arts plastiques pour les enfants
le pédiatre pour les enfants et les
enfants et un poney club là bas mais
c'est bien là comme tout le monde
prévient ses proches si vous pouviez de
la coke au queen tous les soirs on vous
féliciteraient pas non alors entre deux
tournages vous avez votre maison avec
johnny depp dans le sud de la france
non me reposer un petit peu voilà la
drees qui passe lui les déviations
d'accès pour business 4 actuellement
alors nous dit on va au marché en
cuisinant mangent ils ont une vie encore
terriblement simple vous vivez une
espèce de bohème très chic un petit peu
comme dans les années 70 les robes star
l'idée comme ça quand vous voyagez avec
johnny depp quand même 30 d'alice qui
vous suivent que dire quand même c'est
pas d'arriver en voyage mais celle aussi
où que des freins
visionnez les meubles non par exemple
j'étais d'un exemple oran le drap qui
recouvre la table à langer par exemple
les enfants soient habitués à la couleur
du drap vanessa prend ce drap tu en
voilà c'est tout ça c'est vrai ah c'est
beau quand vous dites ça mais non mais
aussi parce que moi les enfants et
vivent une vie de bohème eux au fond
c'est vrai qu'on leur a pas tellement de
demander leur avis ne sont pas l'air de
s'en plaindre mais il faut quand même
pas les jeux l'échangé de maison sans
arrêt sans qu'ils aient des choses aussi
qui reconnaissent qu a pour patron
vanessa paradis et johnny depp ch et un
couple parfait c'est le bonheur absolu
donc on va faire une interview je fous
la merde
[Musique]
toujours amoureuse de johnny depp mais
toujours pas mariés donc vous n'aurez
pas qu'il est un peu moins bon ce moment
c'est vrai qu'il a une vilaine des rues
plantaire c'est un dommage d'être tout
le temps séparés dans le sérieux
justement n'est pas tout le temps c'est
vrai il ne néglige pas là non non c'est
caen qui vous a dit je t'aime pour la
dernière fois
c'est à l'est vous avez cadeau qui vous
a fait c'est quoi
si jay bellerose cette thema il
vachement attentionné en plus quand ils
offrent des fleurs il dit pas sa
secrétaire de le faire c'est lui qui va
vraiment les achetés au magasin il
n'oublie jamais votre anniversaire
tu veux te rends compte non plus non
mais céline service pour savoir s'il est
parfait moi je vous le confirme tout de
suite les îles éparses
aujourd'hui elle est parfois quand même
pas bien c'est parfait
il oublie de relever la cuvette des
toilettes
non jamais non c'est un mec formidable
non seulement c'est quoi qui vous énerve
le plus chez lui qu'on ne fasse pas nous
il ad défend des jeunes
j'aime ses défauts est d'accord et
voulait mais il est pardonné il laisse
traîner ses chaussettes
bah ouais mais j'aimerais pas qui
arrange toutes ces agréments ont pu
nommer si vous êtes fan de lui on va
dire un petit peu un tempérament de feu
ouais et qui sait pas toujours très
facile mais mais mais moi ça me plaît
quand même à ces petits à l'eau vincent
rottiers salut c'est laurent baffie tué
sur paris là mais il peut passer
oui bonjour vincent 20 tel qu' on est à
l'antenne
tu es sur paris est ce que tu peux
passer s'il te plaît à la plaine saint
denis
c'est vanessa matz d'une ans et vanessa
paradis qui a parlé de toi l'addict
était formidable et je te la passe donc
même pas le cul on t'attend moi aussi je
t'embrasse
je te passe vanessa à l'eau non mais si
toi
non mais c'est mais ouais mais je n'y
suis pour rien j'ai juste voulu dire des
gens
[Applaudissements]
alors
alors quand en plus il est devenu mais
non ils veulent que tu ne viens pas du
repas bien si on va parler
il
mon ange wayne et y a plein mon nom mais
il a mieux à faire il à la fête de la
musique c'est ça c'est bien cette
semaine tandis que la faille a de lui
même et j'ai beaucoup de tendresse pour
les jeux la date d'arrivée ça bien et
c'est ainsi pas sonné samedi a pu la
fête de la musique celle dans la peau
qui viennent à l'est et vanessa elle
adore ça jusqu'à johnny depp jeu serait
jaloux mois elle cadors l habitat 18
balles étaient hyper mignon à la dig up
il venait d'avoir 18 ans elle a même
chanté enfin il dit que c'est une belle
aventure avec toi mais qui passe de
minutes à nous raconter bon en tout cas
là on t'attend je crois qu'il a passée
tu peux le mettre les choses au point
[Applaudissements]
non
deux trois petites questions diverses
donc il est parfait c'est johnny depp
évidemment il râle pas quand il faut
descendre la poubelle non mais rallye
il a des manies qui vous énerve quand
même oh là là quand même bien d'accord
vous l'avez déjà chopé en train de
regarder un film porno non non bon ben
c'est sans espoir les corrections de ne
rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus